[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE SMITH: Well, good
afternoon, everybody.
Oh, come on.
I got nothing?
Good afternoon, everybody!
[APPLAUSE]
There we go.
Well, thank you so much for
spending your time with me
today.
My name is Dave Smith.
I'm a Developer
Advocate here at Google
working on the Android
Things platform.
And I'm here today to talk to
you a little bit about building
apps for the Android
Things platform
and how you can be more
effective in the apps
that you build using
the Android SDK.
So whether you're new to
Android or whether you've
been building Android
apps since the beginning,
targeting Android
Things devices--
it has some subtle differences
from what you may or may not
be used to in
working with Android.
Understanding these
differences is
what will ensure
that you can build
better apps on the platform.
But before we jump
into too much of that,
let me just do a quick overview
of what Android Things is,
maybe for the uninitiated.
So Android Things is a
fully-managed platform
for building connected
devices at scale.
It's a variant of
the Android platform
that is optimized for
use in embedded devices.
It enables you to
build apps for embedded
in IoT using the same
Android SDK and Google Play
services that you use to
build for [INAUDIBLE] mobile.
You can develop apps using the
same tools, such as Android
Studio, to deploy and debug
your apps to devices as well.
It includes the Android
Things Developer Console.
This is a place where
you can securely
manage your software
stability and security
updates for your devices.
You simply upload your
apps, choose the OS version
that you want to
run on your device,
and then deploy those updates
to those devices over the air.
Security updates are even
deployed automatically
to those devices for you.
Android Things also
supports powerful hardware
that's suitable for edge
computing and production,
capable of driving artificial
intelligence and machine
learning out to the edge.
This hardware is packaged
into system-on modules that
make it easy for
you to integrate
into your final
production designs.
So when you look at all
these things together,
the process is a little
bit different than when
you were building apps
on a mobile device.
Building a typical app
for Android devices
means distributing a
single app binary--
through the Google
Play Store, typically.
Apps have to work on multiple
devices made by multiple OEMs
targeting multiple versions of
the Android operating system,
typically requiring you to
do various compatibility
checks and other things
like that to make sure
that your app runs well
across that entire breadth
of the ecosystem.
With Android Things,
you are the device OEM.
You control when the
OS on your device
gets upgraded, and
the various apps that
are bundled into that
system image along with it.
And you do all of this through
the Android Things Console
instead of through
the Google Play Store.
This can greatly
simplify your code,
because you don't
need to incorporate
a lot of those same
compatibility checks.
But there are some things
to consider that are going
to be a little bit different.
Let's start with displays.
In Android Things,
displays are optional.
They're supported, and you can
use the full Android UI toolkit
to build applications
that have a Graphical User
Interface, whether it's
touch-enabled or not.
But we've removed a lot
of the default system UI
and disabled or reworked
some of the APIs
that assume that
graphical displays are
in place, because many
IoT devices will not
have these pieces,
and we don't want
to place those
requirements in there.
The best example of this in
practice is App Permissions.
So in Android
Things, permissions
are not granted at
runtime by the end user,
because we can't assume that
there's a graphical display
to show things like this dialog.
And we can't even really
assume that user granting
specific types of permissions is
appropriate for an IoT device.
So instead, these
permissions are actually
granted by you, the developer,
using the Android Things
Console, OK?
So as the owner of
your device, you're
responsible for taking
control of the apps that
run on this device,
and the permissions
that those particular
applications have, OK?
Now, because of
this, permissions
may not be granted by end users.
So that means you
don't necessarily
have to check whether or not
those permissions were grant--
or you don't have to request
for those permissions
to be granted at runtime.
But since they are still
granted dynamically,
the best practice is
still for your code
to verify that you have
that permission, OK?
Because that
permission could have
been revoked by one
of the console users,
and you don't want
your application code
to behave improperly
in those cases.
So you'll still
want to have checks
like this one in your code
when you are accessing
dangerous permissions that
could be granted or revoked
by the console,
but you won't have
to include the code that
requests those permissions
upfront from the end user.
Not doing this will result in
the same security exception
that you would
otherwise see by trying
to access those protected
permissions if, in fact,
that permission is disabled.
Additionally, in
Android Things 1.0,
permissions are no longer
granted automatically
on reboot.
This is something that we did
in some of the earlier previews
and is no longer the case.
So that means that
as a developer,
you can't simply just
reboot your device
to try and get all those
permissions brought
into your app automatically.
You have to actually use the
tooling to make that happen.
So during development, what
you're going to want to do
is provide the -g flag when
installing the applications
on your device.
And this will grant all
the permissions requested
by your app by default.
Android Studio actually
does this for you automatically.
So whenever you click Build
and Run out of the IDE,
this process is taken
care of for you.
But if you want to do this
from the command line,
you're going to have to
add that flag yourself.
Another option is to use the
[? pm ?] [? (grant) ?] command
to individually grant or
revoke permissions inside
of your application.
You can do this
during development,
or maybe just to test what
the individual behavior is
of a certain
permission if you deny
that inside of your application.
If you prefer to use
the Gradle command line,
or perhaps you're running
automated tests or other things
where the IDE is
not involved, you
can actually add this to
your build.gradle file using
an adbOptions block to apply
that same -g flag any time
your application is installed.
Speaking of UI, we should
probably talk a little bit
about activities.
Most developers think that
activities are essentially
screens.
So if we remove displays, why
do we need to keep them around?
And it turns out that
activities are a little bit more
than that.
An activity
represents a component
of user focus in Android.
For devices with
graphical displays,
that does mean that it will
render the contents of the view
onto the window.
But even for devices
without displays,
activities also handle all
of the user input events,
whether that's coming from
a touch screen input--
or maybe it's a game
controller or a keyboard--
or any other
external input device
that you may have connected.
All of those events are going to
be delivered to the foreground
activity.
So even without a
graphical display,
activities are still a
very important portion
of Android user interface,
even though the user interface
might not actually
include the Graphical UI.
It's important to
note, also, when
we're talking about activities
that activities are still
vulnerable to configuration
changes the same way
that they are on Android.
So as an Android
developer, you're
probably used to, at
least at some point,
having to deal with an
orientation change of a device
and having that
destroy your activity
and recreate a new
instance of it.
That's effectively a very
common configuration change
on Android mobile devices.
While on Android Things,
that specific instance
probably is not very common--
if it would happen at all--
there are still a number of
other configuration changes
that might still happen
on Android Things devices.
Things like changing
the default locale
or connecting or
disconnecting a keyboard--
a physical keyboard--
from the device.
All of these events
have the same net effect
in that that activity will
be destroyed and recreated
if it happens to be
in the foreground.
So generally speaking, if
you're working with activities
on Android Things,
the same rules
apply to activities
in terms of the logic
that you put into
those components.
They're effectively
just as fragile in terms
of their lifecycle.
So you're only going to want to
have view-based logic or user
interface-based logic
inside of these activities.
Try not to put too
much additional state
into these components.
You're going to want
to push that out
into other parts of
your application.
Android Things even
uses activities
to launch your
primary application
as part of the boot process.
We do this using the
HOME intent, which
is the same intent that's used
to trigger the App Launcher
on an Android mobile device.
This intent starts your
app automatically on boot--
and specifically the activity
inside of that application--
started automatically on boot.
And in addition to that,
if that application
crashes or terminates
for any reason,
Android is going to restart
that application automatically.
So this becomes the
main entry point
into your application that
is automatically managed
by the Android Things platform.
So we don't want to forget
about activities just yet.
Couple other things about
Android Things devices.
Android Things devices
are also relatively
memory-constrained
when you compare them
to an Android phone.
A typical Android
Things device may have
512 megabytes of RAM or so.
Compare that with the
multiple gigabytes of RAM
that you would have on an
Android phone-- like, say,
a Pixel or a Pixel 2.
What this translates to
for you, the developer
is that there's actually a
much lower per-process heap
size for your
individual application.
So if you're not
familiar with this idea,
Android sets a fixed heap level
on every application running
on that device, and
it's significantly lower
than the total available
memory on that device.
And since the Android
Things devices
are relatively
memory-constrained,
that per-process limit
is significantly lower
than it would be on
an Android phone.
Because of that, if you're
porting code from an Android
mobile device over
to Android Things,
you just have to
realize that if you're
using the same amount
of memory in your app,
there's going to be a
lot less free memory
in that same process
available to you, OK?
So you have to
keep that in mind.
And you also want to
realize that this can also
translate into a significantly
larger amount of garbage
collection events happening as
you allocate new objects, OK?
So you want to keep a close
eye on object allocations,
how often you're doing
object allocations.
Because you may run
into that ceiling
much more quickly
than you otherwise
would on an Android
device, or you
might see the garbage collector
kicking in quite a bit more.
The Memory Profiler
in Android Studio
is a really great resource to
help you keep an eye on what's
going on inside your memory.
It will allow you to track
those allocations over time,
as well as see, overlaid into
it, the individual garbage
collection events.
So you can get a really
good idea of whether or not
your application is
allocating too much memory
and causing trouble.
Some of the things
that you can do
to help understand your
device a little bit better
is use some of the
ActivityManager methods
to do some inspection on
the memory capabilities
of your particular device.
So for example, you can use
the MemoryClass attribute
on ActivityManager.
This will give you the
exact heap size that's
available to your application.
The value that is returned
is the value in megabytes.
That is how much
memory you have.
The largeMemoryClass attribute
is what your application
would have if you
added the large heap
attribute to your manifest.
I would caution you against
doing this on Android Things.
Generally speaking, because
Android Things devices are
memory-constrained,
the MemoryClass
and the largeMemoryClass
of these devices
are generally configured
to be the same value.
So adding this attribute
to your manifest
is essentially not going
to do anything, OK?
You also want to inspect the low
memory threshold of this device
to get a sense for what
that actually looks like.
When the available
memory on the device
falls below that
memory threshold,
the device is in a state
that we call memory pressure.
And we're going to talk a little
bit more about what that means
and why it's important
in a little bit,
but just keep it
in mind for now.
So I want you to
notice something else
about this diagram
that I had up before.
Because of this
per-process heap limit
that's a fixed value for
a single application,
if you try to put all
of your application code
into a single process
or a single APK,
you're going to be severely
limited in your ability
to fully utilize the memory that
is available on this device,
OK?
Now, keep in mind,
with Android Things,
the only apps on the
device are your apps.
So you should be able to take
full advantage of those memory
resources as much
as you possibly can.
The way to do that is to
split your application
into multiple processes, OK?
Because that limit essentially
will apply to each one of those
processes individually.
So if you can federate the
design of your application
out into multiple
components that are actually
running in separate
APKs, you're going
to have a much better
ability to fully utilize
the memory available on whatever
device that you're running.
To make the most effective
use of our device,
we're going to break this
app up into multiple APKs,
with the primary
activity running
in the foreground and additional
apps running in the background
with support services
running inside.
The additional benefit of
running this architecture
is that it actually insulates
these various components
from one another.
So in this scenario,
if a crash happens
in one of these components, it's
localized just to that element.
And it won't bring down
your entire application
and have you have to restart
all of that from the beginning.
So you can manage those
individual issues just
within that component and leave
the rest of the applications
or components running on
your device to be unaffected.
It also means that you
can launch or relaunch
these components individually
as needed by your application.
So if you don't need to load
everything at once at boot,
you can launch various
services and components
just as you need them.
Now, it turns out the decision
to put some of your components
into background apps has
consequences as well.
Android treats foreground
and background processes
a little bit
differently, and we need
to be aware of what's going
on under the hood here.
Android marks
application processes
by priority based on how
closely they are related
to the foreground application.
And this is very important
because of a system process
known as the low memory killer.
The low memory
killer is a process
that is constantly
prowling in the background,
looking for new
processes to devour.
Its job is to ensure that
the free memory on the system
is available to the foreground
app at any given time.
So if the foreground app needs
new memory and the device
happens to be in a system
of memory pressure,
low memory killer is going to
go hunting around for processes
that it can terminate to
allocate that memory back
to the foreground, OK?
On an Android device-- like
a typical user-driven Android
device--
this can be somewhat
of a nuisance
to developers, because
their app may get
terminated from the background.
But at some point, the user's
going to relaunch it later,
and everything will be fine.
On Android Things,
the low memory killer
could mean that you have
critical device functionality
that is being terminated
out from underneath you,
and you didn't even know it.
Perhaps there's a device
driver running in that service
and Android killed
that because it
thought it was low enough
priority in the background, OK?
So something to keep in mind
as you're moving through this.
In addition, Android Oreo
introduced execution limits
for background apps.
So applications can
no longer be started
into a background state.
They must either be launched
from the foreground app
or bound to it in some way.
So because of these
two things, there's
a number of
different common ways
that you may or may not
have used in the past
to launch components
into the background, OK?
And we're going to walk
through those a little bit.
So the first that you
might be familiar with
is using the
BOOT_COMPLETED broadcast
to listen for a final boot
message coming from the Android
framework saying that the
system is up and running,
you can launch other
apps if you would like.
Do not use this
on Android Things.
The primary reason is because
of those background execution
limits, your background
services actually
can't be properly
started into that state.
In a lot of cases, it
won't even work, OK?
And in addition to
that, this background
broadcast-- this
BOOT_COMPLETED broadcast--
is very unpredictable
in terms of its timing.
In a lot of cases, this
BOOT_COMPLETED broadcast
actually triggers
much, much later
than when the home intent
and the home activity
are fully up and running
in the foreground, OK?
So if you're trying to
synchronize between these two
things, it's not a very
good mechanism to rely on.
In addition, I would recommend
you don't use startService.
For a similar
reason, startService
is limited by those same
background execution limits
unless you are starting a
service in foreground mode.
Now, foreground services
require you, as a developer,
to actually build in
a notification that
would typically
display to the user
when that service is running.
Well, we took away the system
UI where that notification would
display, so you end up
doing a bunch of work
for displaying the service
that doesn't actually
gain you anything.
And in addition to that,
there are some difficulties
with started services
when it comes
to managing their lifecycle.
A started service-- if that
crashes for some reason,
you don't have a
direct connection
to understand that that
occurred and that you
need to restart that
service so that you
can manage that process
a little bit better.
Now, Android does have this
thing that services can return
this START_STICKY
attribute, and that's
a way for applications
to tell Android
that this service is important,
and if it crashes or terminates
for some reason, I need
it to be restarted.
However, Android usually only
does this about once or twice
for a given service before
they just sort of give
up and realize
that at some point,
the user will launch
this app again.
Maybe this will start again and
everything will be fine, OK?
That type of thinking
doesn't go well
for those background
services that
have critical functionality in
them-- like a device driver,
OK?
So we recommend you use
bindService instead.
By using bound
services, this gives
the background processes
an active connection
to that foreground app, OK?
So you have a good indication
of when that service is running
and when that service
has died for some reason
so that you can manage that,
relaunch it if you need to,
do any of those things.
This also has the added benefit
of a built-in communication
channel between the
applications that are bound.
So you can do some more direct
communication with that service
without having to use
intents or other mechanisms
like that to pass
data back and forth.
So looking at this
diagram again,
one of the other important
reasons to use bound services
is that pure background
applications--
like those that would have
been started by BOOT_COMPLETED
or just startService
on its own--
are very low priority
on the scale, OK?
Whereas bound
service applications
are almost as high priority
as the foreground app.
They are literally
the highest priority
you can get without
being the foreground app.
So this ensures that
those background processes
stay safe from something
like low memory killer
if the device ever does get into
a memory pressure situation,
OK?
So you get better management
of those services,
and you get better protection
from a memory management
perspective.
All right, let's take a look
at what this would actually
look like in code.
So I have just a basic
example of a service here
that has a device
driver inside of it.
In this case, this is
just a device driver
to take some button inputs and
convert them into key events
like they were coming
off of a keyboard.
All of this logic can
be fully encapsulated
into this external service
and can run on its own.
So we can build this
service component.
And then from the
foreground app,
we can construct an intent
to that service component,
and we can bind to it.
Notice that I'm doing this
from the Application class
and not from the
primary activity.
Remember our discussion
from activities before
and the lifecycle
associated with those.
If this is a service
that needs to be
as persistent as
possible, we want
to bind to it from a
component that is expected
to be around just as long, OK?
So that you don't end
up with lifecycle issues
where your activity
gets destroyed,
recreated, and you're rebinding
to that service unnecessarily.
Doesn't necessarily
cause a major problem,
but it's not the best idea.
In addition, with
bound services,
this also means that you get
this feedback mechanism coming
through the service
connection callback.
So when you bind
to a service, you
provide this callback
as a service connection.
And when the service
is up and running,
you will be notified through
the onServiceConnected method.
So you know exactly
when this is now
something you can interact
with or communicate
with if you need to.
In addition,
onServiceDisconnected
tells us anytime that
service stops unexpectedly--
maybe because it has crashed
or something else has occurred.
And at that point,
we probably need
to take a look at
restarting this,
especially if it's running
some critical functionality
on our device.
So we now have the information
we need to properly manage
this functionality from
within our applications, which
we wouldn't get with started
services or other of these more
independent mechanisms.
So here's a final picture
of that architecture again.
Android is going to manage
for us automatically
that foreground app
using the HOME intent.
It will launch it
automatically on boot,
and it will relaunch it if
that application crashes
for any reason.
And then our application
code can then
manage these additional
background support services
through the bound
service mechanism.
All right, the last thing that
I want to share with you today
are just a couple of
quick tips on doing
this type of development
from within Android Studio,
or within the development tools.
So you can manage multiple APKs
from within a single Android
Studio project by adding
each additional package
as a new module.
You can add multiple
modules to the same project,
and all of those modules
can represent an APK
or an individual app process.
This allows you to manage all
of your code in one place,
even though they're
technically separate apps.
Now, by default,
Android Studio does not
allow you to deploy an
app module that does not
contain a launcher activity,
or an activity that
has that main launcher
intent filter on it.
This doesn't work so well
for background service
apps that don't have any
activities at all in them
in some cases.
But you can modify
this behavior.
For a background
services app, you
can edit the run
configuration and simply
adjust the launch options for
that particular module, set
that target to Nothing
instead of Default Activity.
This will enable Android Studio
to deploy that service-only app
to your device, and
it won't complain.
You can also do this
from the command line.
And one of the advantages
of doing it this way
is that Android Studio does
require that you deploy
only one module at a time--
by selecting that module
from the run configuration
list in the UI.
So if you have an
application that's
constructed of four or
five different modules
all as individual APKs,
it can be a bit cumbersome
if you have to try
and deploy them
all individually all the time.
One of the advantages of
using the Gradle command line
is that by default, when you
run a command like installDebug
with no other modifiers,
it builds and installs
every module in that project.
So with one command, you
can deploy everything
on the latest version
to that device.
And you can still do
individual modules,
if you would prefer to do that,
by just adding the module name
to the command as well.
Once you've got the
modules on the device,
the other thing
you can do directly
from the command line
that isn't really
supported in
Android Studio today
is the ability to start
those individual components,
whether their
activities or services.
So using the am
shell commands, you
can trigger those
services manually
if you want to test out
some of that behavior
independently from the
rest of the system,
even though they may be
managed by the foreground
app in production.
All right, so let's quickly
review some of the tips
that we've gone
through here today.
Don't assume a graphical UI.
Design for your memory
constraints on these devices.
Break your app up into modules.
Bind your background services
to the foreground app.
Don't use started services.
And use the Gradle
command line if you
want to have more
control over deploying
your modules to the device.
Now, if you're just as excited
about Android Things as we are,
I want to remind everyone
that we're doing a scavenger
hunt here at Google I/O. If
you visit the link here or use
the Google I/O app, you can
follow the instructions to find
various items around
the conference.
And once you've completed
those challenges,
you can then receive a free
Android Things developer kit
to take home.
To learn more about
Android Things,
visit the developer
site and make
sure to visit the Codelabs,
office hours, and other demos
that we have here
in the Sandbox.
Also be sure to visit Android
Things with Google.com
to find featured community
projects and additional sample
code.
You'll also find a
lot of the sample code
available for some
of the demos that we
have here at the conference on
androidthings.withgoogle.com
as well.
So thank you, everyone,
for your time today,
and I'm really excited
to see the apps
that you build with
Android Things.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]